might be  is it just completely winning for white  because f7 is dropping no your rook on  f8 is attacked yeah exactly i mean it  seems like yeah not important already  for for the results but  but a very big win for for prague is  about to happen again yeah it's uh  that's amazing i i just can't see  i i mean basically now you go look b7  and you force designation yeah rugby 8  is a sled  and that's it that's it and prague  immediately finds it king eight seven  runs into rook f7 and it's game over our  tamiya resigns  pragananda might not be in but what a  star performance in this tournament  peter the 16 year old beat love on our  onion he beat magnus carlsen and now our  time we have vladislav  yeah absolutely i mean i'm so happy for  all the youngsters getting this chance  and immediately i think they make the  whole tournament the whole tour  incredibly colorful uh new heroes to to  cheer for and also one can see that it's  just a method of time